Washington Post she's a personal finance
writer and yesterday the Fed did some
things with credit card regulations
Nancy trejos what did they do yes they
did they actually approved some really
sweeping reforms of the credit card
industry what they did is they approved
regulations that would forbid credit
card companies from raising interest
rates on the existing balances unless
the consumer was 30 days or more late
they also forbid credit card companies
from raising are from charging late fees
unless the consumer was given at least
21 days to pay their bill and they
banned several other unfair and
deceptive practices unfair and deceptive
such as such as the raising of the
interest rates on existing balances and
charging excessive late fees and also
say they actually told chronic credit
card companies that they have to
allocate payments in the way in which
the balances with the highest interest
rates get repaid first did the credit
card companies fight these regulations
new regulations they did these
regulations were first proposed back in
May and the credit card companies fought
them they said you know what if this
happens you're going to ruin the economy
because we're not going to be able to
give out credit but they finally in the
last few months that's the recession got
worse they gave up they realize this is
going to happen and we have to show that
we want to help consumers let's put the
numbers up on the screen we're talking
about the new credit card regulations
and the credit card industry 202 is the
area code you can see the numbers there
/ political affiliation go ahead and
dial in we're talking with Nancy trejos
who is a personal finance writer for The
Washington Post ms trejos did when do
these regulations take effect not until
July 2010 which the consumer groups are
quite upset about because that's a
really long time why so long from now
well the credit card company said you
know we need a long time to to implement
this we had to change our consumer
our computer systems we have to change
our disclosures of terms and conditions
is this something that the Congress
could have done well they can and and
they're considering doing this I think
there's going to be a lot going on in
Congress next year in terms of credit
card regulation this past year several
members of Congress actually introduced
bills that would have changed credit
card regulations and gone even farther
than the Fed did and they intend to do
so again next year now the Fed
regulations go into effect can the
Congress veto them can they change them
know that the Fed regulations are going
to go into effect as is what Congress
can do is codify them so Congress next
year will come back and I'm sure we're
going to see a slew of bills introduced
regarding credit card regulations and I
think some of the members of Congress
even want to go they want it they want
stronger regulation or credit cards so
they can come up with their own rules
and you touched on this but you said
that some consumer groups were upset
that it was going to take so long from
now is there any recourse no you know
it's it's going to go into effect in
July because the consumer groups are
just hoping that Congress will step in
and and pass their own rules that would
go into effect before july two thousand
ten do the credit card companies make a
lot of money off late fees and their
current situation the way they've got it
set up so they do and there was one
report that came out by some industry
analysts that showed that if these rules
go into it into effect the credit card
companies stand to lose about 12 billion
dollars from from the money they get out
of interest payments from interest and
for late fees right for 12 billion
dollars in annual revenue are Americans
addicted to credit cards I think so you
know we've become you know it's it's
generation that I mean we've we've
become so hooked on our credit cards the
it's a it's a 960 billion dollar
industry I mean that's how much
revolving debt there is
you know people have gotten so
especially in the past year so when you
know when when they could they'd lost
the equity in their homes so they
couldn't tap into their home equity
lines of credit they started using their
credit cards even more and and for every
day cost to you know it's not just the
going out and buying some luxury items
it's it's paying your electric bill with
it and as a personal finance writer what
is your advice unis just right now we're
in a recession I think everyone needs to
be conservative don't get into anymore
debt try to pay down the debt that you
have you know that's difficult to do but
you know you just want to be
conservative with your money right now
it seems that the the slew of mail that
one gets from credit card company saying
signup here signup here signup here has
slowed down it has why well because in
this economy everyone all the financial
institutions are really skittish about
lending money you know even though the
federal government has done everything
they can essentially to to make it
easier for financial institutions to
lend money they don't want to do it
they're there they're afraid they're
losing money and and they're just kind
of hoarding their money right now let's
take some calls fort myers florida
you're on with Nancy trejos of the
washington post personal finance rider
good morning an excuse have a cold here
hey I have a question one thing I've
noticed that I at at one point in the
history of with my credit card and I had
been a long-standing person with that
particular card I took out a cash
advance well the next month I really
paid off the amount to cash advance was
but I noticed that they did not apply it
to the amount that was a cash advance
portion they just applied it to the
general balance and continue to charge
me the interest rate that was a cash
advance which you know as you probably
know is substantially higher I'm
wondering is that going to change then
some of the new rules and you all have a
wonderful Christmas holiday
the rules don't say anything
specifically about cash advances what
what it does do it does dictate payment
allocation in terms of of just regular
balances a lot of times consumers will
have balances with different interest
rates what the credit card companies
have done in the past is that they've
applied any any amount above the minimum
payment to the balance with the lowest
rate that they make more money off that
because your balance with with a higher
interest rate lingers longest so what
what the Fed has said is from now on
credit card companies are either going
to have to apply the payment first to
the balance with the highest interest
rate or allocated proportionately be
tuned up among all the balances brooklyn
new york hey are you first-time caller
well first add this is a reaction to the
usual route the usually laws um you know
when they changed the law they did it
when they change the laws I think it was
a couple years ago um they had like a
gotcha mentality so for example if you
missed the car payment they would just I
don't know they would just raise your
interest rate on your credit card even
though you missed the car payment you're
paying your credit card on times it
would raise your car payment and the
other thing I want to also ask you was
being that I'm guess we're going to go
back to normalcy um oh this will
probably affect how would this probably
affect the mortgage payments or the way
the banking industry approaches a
mortgage just because I in the past I
worked as a loan office and I couldn't
believe the gotcha mentality that they
had as well um you know you just miss
one payment and then the difference
between your payments versus you know
what it was you know what they were
charged if you never miss anything was
just astronomical and I think you know I
mean just really pretty much like I said
the gotcha mentality or in terms of like
and will be much where many asking is so
miss a car payment as well as the though
the mortgage
industry goes to really question I were
you hoping to answer from well I think
what you're talking about is universal
default and it's a practice in which the
credit card companies will raise your
interest rate if you miss any payments
on other debts meaning let's say you
have a citibank card you're paying your
citibank card on time but you you you
know you miss a mortgage payment then
the citibank citibank would raise your
interest rate again it's known as
universal default these rules do not do
not change that unfortunately how can
that be you know it they can do it if
you know the credit card industry before
now was not all that regulated there are
many practices that like universal
default that they've just been able to
do over over the last few years how do
they get that information on a regular
basis they go to your credit report so
they look at your credit report and they
if they see oh you know that this person
didn't pay their mortgage to bank of
america where a citibank it doesn't
matter we're going to raise the interest
rate that's something that that Congress
really is going to look at but for now
that that's that's still there although
I have to say some of the credit card
companies on their own have stopped this
practice because it's been so
controversial what's the thought process
behind a credit card company increasing
your payment when if you're late on
another payment I mean is there a
rationale there well in their mind you
become riskier your your your high risk
and so they feel that they're taking on
this risk and therefore they can
increase your payments next call for
Nancy trejos Conway South Carolina good
morning good morning yes thank you for
taking my call I have a question that
I've wondered about for quite a long
time when I was in college back in the
dark ages I remember that I got tons of
offers from credit card companies um and
I was a college student did not have a
job not have a lot of money so I'm
wondering how is it that credit card
companies can target college students
you probably are very risky
and probably a lot of them I would
imagine get themselves in trouble by
taking one of those credit cards and
start using them i'm wondering if any of
the regulations the new regulations that
is do any of them address that no and
that and that was also controversial i
mean there were the consumer groups
wanted that to be addressed i mean that
that is a huge problem aggressive
marketing to college students with some
of these credit card companies will go
on these campuses and and give iPods to
t students so that they'll apply for
credit cards again members of Congress
are very aware of this and several the
bills that were introduced this past
year addressed that issue and they want
to ban this aggressive marketing do you
foresee credit card regulation in the
hundred and 11th congress i I do
actually I I think actually one of the
bills passed last year representative
Carolyn Maloney's credit card holder
Bill of Rights actually passed the house
it did not get voted on in the Senate
basically they ran out of time so I know
she definitely wants to bring up her
bill again senator Dodd has indicated
that he wants to as well senator Levin
and Barney Frank has said that you know
this is going to be a priority what does
a credit card bill of rights credit card
holder Bill of Rights do well Carolyn
Maloney's really mirrored the Federal
Reserve's regulations it essentially was
the same thing so it would codify it
would put it into law but some of the
other bills go a lot a lot further I
mean so there's one that addresses
aggressive marketing there's a few that
address the whole universal default so I
think we're going to see a more
regulation Fort Belvoir Virginia
Republican hi good morning merry
Christmas to everyone at c-span I just
wanted to say that it's it's great that
you can never provide too much education
on you know how to deal with credit card
companies but what's amazing to me is
that the Federal Reserve is the one that
they're putting in charge of this and
through this whole banking mess the
Federal Reserve is what they're giving
more powers too it's an unconstitutional
by a few private families and it's
amazing to me that you know that the
press of course is just owned by them so
they never report on them Ron Paul talks
about it Dennis Kucinich talks about it
but you'll never hear anything in the
school's you'll never hear anything in
the press and I think they do a great
disservice to this country by not
talking about the history of the Federal
Reserve I mean it was passed on
Christmas Day because they knew that
they were giving away the country to the
bankers well well actually to be fair
these rules were not just approved by
the Federal Reserve it's the Federal
Reserve the office of Thrift Supervision
and the National Credit Union
Administration the three of them got
together to do this because the Federal
Reserve is overseeing the banks the
credit unions is what the National
Credit Union Administration overseas
obviously and the office of Thrift
Supervision oversees the savings
association so they wanted to cover all
the financial institutions why did they
decide in May of this year to look at re
regulating the credit card industry well
because again the consumer advocates
were really really pushing for this
members of Congress were pushing for
some sort of changes as well you know
what was happening is that people were
having a hard time paying their credit
card bills a lot of people were
complaining about these high interest
rates these these high fees these fees I
would just show up on their on their
statements that they didn't understand
and it just became clear as the economy
got worse default started rising
delinquency delinquency started rising
and therefore you know it just got to
the point where it was just too too much
Rio Grande Valley Texas good morning
good morning c-span thank you for
providing this work well let the
American citizen I i really want to ask
your guests there how does she feel
about the credit card companies being
able to borrow money at zero percent
perhaps and charging thirty percent to a
lot of underprivileged poor people
sure how she feels about that and asked
her why any legislation that doesn't
come to for 42 years is really a
responsible piece of legislation well
obviously as a journalist I can't give
my opinion but is that color accurate
about that it is true that that as these
interest rates as the Fed has cut
interest rates it hasn't always
translated into relief for consumers and
again the reason for that is that these
financial institutions are very skittish
about about their ability to have cash
in hand they've lost a lot of money and
therefore you know if they were to to
lower interest rates dramatically I mean
that they're afraid they just won't have
enough money but even though it doesn't
make sense that if people can't afford X
number of dollars by increasing their
payment they're not going to be able to
afford that but maybe cutting their
payment they could afford that does that
make economic sense you know that I mean
that's that's the argument you know that
it does make sense obviously you know
people are having a hard time paying
their bills so does it really make sense
to increase their interest rates so that
they can't pay their bills you know the
consumer groups they know Yellville
Arkansas you're on with Nancy trejos of
the Washington Post good morning I might
kill Whitaker and I I had some problems
with him are we get feedback please go
ahead with your comment sir okay I my
wife I were having trouble making our
payments with bank america on our fedex
art thing of it is we'd mail the payment
in around the second or third of the
month and we would be due on say the
15th or 20th and we kept getting late
fees so we call them up and ask them and
they said it wouldn't have anything to
do with when it was postmarked when they
got around to opening it single it is
gone get interest rates off 39 down to
say nine or ten and then the next month
be right back up there
and I wondering if its regulations
donuts problem doing that because that's
just ripping people off Thank You caller
Nancy trejos yes actually that that is
one of the main parts of this regulation
is regulating how the banks can charge
late fees you're right i mean a lot of
the credit card companies have not given
consumers enough time to pay their bills
and so now this regulation says they
must give consumers at least 21 days
what does that mean from the time they
mail it at the time they mail your
statement to your due date it has to be
at least 21 days and what is it now is
there any there is nothing now they
could you know they could mail it five
days before so okay richwood west
virginia go ahead yeah Nancy I have same
problem pretty much the color before
that it was the credit company whenever
they decide that not the deal problem
but what what I would like to know is
why watch July 2010 I mean why does it
take that long to make an effect on this
you know the banks the credit card
companies actually wanted two years the
consumer groups wanted this to be done
right away or you know about 180 days
from now this was kind of the compromise
a year and a half uh burtonsville
Maryland good morning I like to know um
I took out a loan last year for a
motorcycle like 3500 hours and was for
some explode after year into it and four
thousand dollars I spin on it I call the
finance company to ask them about my
finest artists and they explaining that
I can't talk to anybody in the finance
group or nothing like that and so I
stopped payment and I want drones
channels I'm talking to my senators now
and I've already been told that there
was fraudulent information there there's
no viable deal cuz it work states no
interest rate anything like that but i
still owe I've craters calling target
their money but I've also been told that
I don't the paper the diddly diddly go
on repossessed the bike the VIN numbers
don't match I mean nothing known as
right but i still owe my credits going
down and all ages I've grown to work for
you tell me they can't do anything
except ask for information mr. Bush bank
then at the given so what do I do thank
you call well it sounds like a
complicated situation and you know I
don't know all the details of it but I
would you know obviously keep calling
your lender and and trying to negotiate
some sort of solution and is that a
different case since that's a actual
object like a car or a motorcycle that
could be repossessed a different case in
that credit card yes well it's a yes I
mean it's it's much different than a
credit card but you know again you just
have to sort of negotiate with your
lender and and if that doesn't work I
mean I would seek some help from of a
financial advisor or a credit counselor
why are the credit card company saying
that these regulations could make it
harder for people to obtain credit cards
but what they're saying is that they
won't be able to manage their risk
properly they like to be able to charge
different interest rates for different
people depending on that person's risk
so they'll look at your credit history
and they'll say okay you get a twenty
percent interest rate but you get a
fifteen percent interest rate what
they're saying is that these regulations
now limit their ability to do that and
therefore that they can't spread the
risk and so they'll just have to charge
higher rates for everyone even if your
credit worthy last call Aberdeen
Maryland Aberdeen oh yeah please go
ahead oh yeah I have a credit card that
I've another worthless so many months
and all I have all I have an insurer
body confidence and I can't get much
help from the insurance and I'm angry
about it I rocket hurt somebody
but without insurance and I want to
ensure that you step off the plate I
gracefully bow to do all right thanks
Nancy trejos do you answer questions
like that in a personal finance column
for The Washington Post I lied to you
actually I have a column that runs every
Sunday and what I do is I take readers
questions and I try to get them some
some advice from some professionals try
to help them out there's a lot of people
right now who are drowning in debt and
and are having problems just keeping up
with the cost of living so I'm getting
tons of questions these days and how do
people get questions to you they can
email me at Trejo San at wash post calm
and I welcome any questions Nancy trejos
personal finance writer for The
Washington Post thanks for being with us
Rachel stassen burgers with the st. Paul
Pioneer Press you've seen her on this
program a couple of times we wanted to
get an update